this is a really bizarre story I don't
really know any other word for it we've
talked about the sort of macro insanity
of the Brett Kavanaugh sexual assault
story we now have multiple allegations
against him from Christine Blasi Ford
from Deborah Ramirez there are
allegations that Cavanaugh was involved
in plying women along with others with
alcohol in order to as a pretext to the
possible a gang rape of these women he
made a very strange statement where he
said he definitely wasn't at the party
where Christine Blasi Ford was allegedly
almost raped but how would you know you
weren't at that specific party if it
didn't happen and you weren't there is
none of it really makes sense right
that's the macro of it so anyway we're
waiting on the hearing to see what dr.
Ford has to say to hear Brett
Cavanaugh's defense senators have been
sort of working out exactly when it's
going to be and in the middle of this
Republican Senator Chuck Grassley
appears to have accidentally tweeted
something that he meant to text to Brett
Kavanaugh Grassley is 85 years old he's
the chair of the Senate Judiciary
Committee meaning he's running the
confirmation hearings for Cavanaugh to
the Supreme Court he's running the
scheduling he's making decisions about
what's happening when and late on Friday
close to midnight Eastern Time on Friday
he tweets the following quote judge
Cavanaugh I just granted another
extension to dr. Ford to decide if she
wants to proceed with the statement she
made last week to testify to the Senate
she should decide so we can move on I
want to hear her I hope you understand
it's not my normal approach to be
indecisive this doesn't really read like
a normal public tweet that a senator
would deliberately send at midnight it
reads more to me like this was supposed
to be a private text message to Brett
Kavanaugh at the same time Grassley does
tweet in generally confusing and unclear
ways so like here's another example of
Grassley's shorthand that he has used in
tweets he once tweeted quote five times
now we've granted extension for dr. Ford
to decide if she wants to proceed with
her desire stated one week ago
that she wants to tell the senator story
dr. Ford if you changed your mind say so
so we can move on I want to hear your
testimony come to us or we to you so on
the one hand it does seem like his first
message was meant to be like a private
text to Brett Kavanaugh on the other
hand particularly for an 85 year old guy
who was not necessarily raised in the
era of social media shorthand he does
seem to regularly use some pretty
consistent shorthand everything about
this story is bizarre down to the
communications between Grassley and
Cavanaugh yeah he looked into the
character count on that first tweet yeah
it was 272 just eight character shy of
the 280 Twitter limit yeah so that
suggests to me that he wrote it up and
then had to delete some characters and
so maybe he thought he was tweeting but
that's that's not something that you
want release with the public that's
something you tell someone one-on-one
yeah yeah maybe he thought it was a
direct message I don't know there's so
many questions here do you think he's
direct messaging with Brett Kavanaugh
that would be even more shocking it may
be this is the transparency we've been
waiting for like instead of
communicating with Kavanaugh privately
Grassley does it through public Twitter
posts just directed at Kavanagh and as
far as the subject matter in Grassley's
defense although he might be sort of
stumbling around in the dark
technologically he does actually seem to
want to get the hearing done with the
Cavanaugh accuser
but he wants to get it done merely to
say we did it we we heard from her and
now we're ready to confirm Brett
Kavanaugh to the Supreme Court and of
course we now have even more information
to suggest that that's what they want to
do because we learned that last week
they were notified about the existence
of a second accuser Debra Ramirez and
instead of saying stop the presses
stop this from going forward we've got
to go back to the drawing board and
investigate all of this stuff
Republicans instead said oh we've got to
hurry up we've got to hurry up and get
Cavanaugh approved for life to the
Supreme Court confirmed for life before
this blows up in our faces now I want to
give you one example of what I mean when
I say Republicans don't care what
Christine Blasi Ford says they just want
to say we heard from her now we're ready
to move on Republican Senator Lindsey
Graham Graham says it doesn't matter
what she says he's not going to change
his
the hearing hasn't happened but he's
saying the content of it is irrelevant
he said on Fox News Sunday yesterday
quote you can't bring it in a criminal
court you would never sue civilly you
couldn't even get a warrant what am I
supposed to do go ahead and ruin this
guy's life based on an accusation I
don't know when it happened I don't know
where it happened and everybody named in
regard to being there said it didn't
happen there's a huge difference between
ruining his life and simply saying he
shouldn't be one of nine appointed for
life judges on the highest court in the
land right that's not the same thing I
can't ruin his life by not buying him a
Lamborghini well there's a difference
between ruining someone's life and not
getting them the luxury sports car that
they want right and the point is the
Republicans who want the hearing don't
want it because they might hear what dr.
Ford has to say and then decide you know
what I can't vote for this guy they want
to do it just so they can check the box
say they did it and move on to confirm
confirming him I don't think any
Republicans are willing to change their
votes
yeah and Lindsey Graham is making it
seem as though we're prosecuting
Cavanaugh and they're proving these
allegations beyond a reasonable doubt
sure that's not what the standard is
here it's just weighing it out out in
the court of public opinion and among
those 100 senators who will vote to
confirm and making a decision as to
whether they are comfortable giving this
guy a job for life deciding the most
important legal cases out there period
for the United States for as long as he
wants to be on the court the answer is
clearly no we actually have other news
related to Brett Kavanaugh as well a lot
of Brett Cavanaugh stuff today so we
talked about the background earlier just
now about sexual assault allegations
against Brett Cavanaugh we had Christine
Blasi for to come forward allegations
from high school we had Deborah Ramirez
come forward allegations from college
about forcing his penis into her face
and and forcing her to touch it without
consent we now have learned about an
individual named James Roche James Roche
was Brett Cavanaugh's roommate at Yale
in 1983 during the time that the Deborah
Ramirez incident allegedly took place
and James Roche has now given an
interview and put out a statement
and what James wrote says is not good
for Cavanaugh he says quote basically
that he believes the accuser sang quote
we shared a two-bedroom unit in the
basement of Lawrence Hall on the old
campus despite our living conditions
Bret and I did not socialize beyond the
first few days of freshman year we
talked at night as freshman roommates do
and I would see him as he returned from
nights out with his friends going on to
say it is from this experience that I
concluded that although Brett was
normally reserved he was a notably heavy
drinker even by the standards of the
time meaning college freshmen in this
this in the early eighties and that he
became aggressive and belligerent when
he was very drunk I did not observe the
specific incident in question but I do
remember Brett frequently drinking
excessively and becoming in coherently
drunk this is important because
Cavanaugh denies drinking to this degree
now as far as the accuser Debbie Ramirez
James Roach again this is Cavanaugh's
college roommate went on the record and
in a statement said quote she stood out
as being exceptionally honest with a
trusting manner as we got to know one
another
I discovered that Debbie was very
worried about fitting in she felt that
everyone at Yale was very rich very
smart and very sophisticated and that as
a Puerto Rican woman from a less
privileged background she was an
outsider her response was to try hard to
make friends and get along how could it
be that so many people are now saying
that Brett Kavanaugh either did certain
things or is exactly the type of guy who
would have done certain things when he
had 65 girls who knew him in high school
who said he's just a great guy now he
did go to an all-boys Catholic school
it's weird to me that 65 girls knew him
well enough to make statements on the
record about exactly what kind of a guy
he was that's a little bit odd but we
can skip over that right now because I
want to sort of circle all of this stuff
Pat back to something that is really
important that has been forgotten
because of all of these sexual assault
allegations which are important the
story about his tens or hundreds of
thousands of dollars of debt related to
baseball tickets is still out there and
it's really a concerning situation I
forgot all about that stuff it feels
like it happened a
years ago the story is important and I
don't want you to let the sketchy debt
story go away
because of the sexual assault stories I
don't want the sexual assault stories to
be ignored because of the perjury stuff
but the sexual assault can be more
easily shrugged off by Republicans by
saying as they will accusers sometimes
lie it's been a long time
these are smears it's a smear campaign
the $200,000 in sketchy baseball ticket
debt can't be explained away as easily
and it's also a much more complicated
story to figure out what it is that
Brett Kavanaugh actually was doing it is
extraordinarily shady but almost
nobody's talking about it anymore and if
you've forgotten about this or never
knew about it to begin with Brett
Kavanaugh had a bunch of debt that was
sort of mysteriously and very quickly
paid off in advance of his 2017
financial disclosure his claim is that
he was buying baseball tickets for
friends on his credit cards and that
then his friends would pay him back and
that he had racked up a ton of debt on
the credit cards but he was paid back lo
and behold by the time he filed this
2017 financial disclosure the debt was
completely gone but does that really
make sense to anybody because it's very
weird that a guy who is not rich at the
time based on his net worth it doesn't
really make sense that he'd be amassing
these tens of thousands of dollars on a
rolling basis adding up to a couple
hundred thousand dollars in credit card
debt reportedly for baseball tickets and
then it all goes away
and we don't know how and it just
absolutely stinks and it's the
sexual-assault stuff is important if he
perjured himself it's important but
there's been no reasonable explanation
for this debt being paid off either yeah
and there were plenty of other judges
conservative judges that Trump could
have picked and I wonder if you know the
sexual assault allegations and maybe to
a lesser extent the baseball ticket
stuff will be a reason for Senate
Republicans to pull the plug on Kavanagh
sometime soon and rush through someone
else I don't think it's their call see
that's the thing the what the
Republicans seem to be doing is
trying to move full speed ahead senator
corn and put out a statement yesterday
saying that if nothing new comes from
Thursday's hearing they're gonna vote on
Cavanaugh Cavanaugh in committee and in
the chamber before adjourn in Friday
that's like three days from now so I
think that as long as Trump doesn't say
we've got to pull them as long as
Cavanaugh doesn't say I'm gonna go away
because it's becoming a distraction I
think the Republicans are sort of
committed to just trying to get him
through and I think for them part of it
is they don't want it it's horrible that
it's become this toxic but if they don't
get Cavanaugh through they won't see it
as this was a bad guy who lied had very
weird debts that were paid off suddenly
and had multiple sexual assault
accusations against them they will say
the Dems won they prevented us from
appointing this guy they get a win we
get a loss even though you shouldn't
want an alleged serial sex assault or on
the Supreme Court so I think that if if
no one else pulls the plug Republicans
are going for it yeah there are some
political pundits saying that if
Cavanaugh is rushed through despite all
of these allegations not getting heard
yeah then he will always have an
asterisk next to his name as a Supreme
Court justice what does that matter in
the end I mean he's going to be able to
serve on the court for what 30 40 years
and that this stuff's not gonna matter
and it's not gonna affect his decision
made only a lifetime appointment Pat
what are you worried about now I do have
to bring this up because the audience
will crush me if I don't did you say
astrick I was thinking about how to
pronounce this word ahead of time and I
still couldn't get it right so yeah if
you want to slam me on that it's fair
game and there's actually one more did
you say pun dent or pundit I think I
said pundit okay let's let's play back
the tape yeah let's do it over let's
roll it back do the entire story over
and cut that out we'll do an overdub
after we go to commercial make sure
you're following the show on instagram
at david pakman show make sure you were
following me on instagram at david
pakman you know who joins me next this
is someone I've been looking forward to
interviewing for a long time you said
we've been working on it since April
since April of 2018
astronaut I guess I have to say retired
astronaut scott kelly is going to join
me he spent a year on the International
station he has a twin brother Mark Kelly
who is of course the husband of former
Congresswoman Gabby Giffords who was
tragically shot in that incident several
years ago now Scott Kelly is going to
join me next I hope you will stay with
us for this one even those of you who
don't love the interviews because I'm
really looking forward to it and I hope
you are as well quick break back after
this I've got for you today the most
cringe-worthy completely bata moment
that any American president in the sort
of modern era of audio-visual recording
has experienced Donald Trump was laughed
at not laughing with but very clearly
laughing at by the entire room of world
leaders at the United Nations General
Assembly yesterday Trump showed up and
he tried the stuff that he says at
rallies of supporters but instead he was
in a room full of world leaders and it
did not go over well what's the phrase
it went over like a lead balloon this
video is so embarrassing
that I almost I'm and the key word is
almost I almost feel bad for the guy but
I don't okay and what Donald Trump did
in the video I'm about to play for you
is he tried to claim that he has
accomplished more in his first two years
as president of the United States than
any other administration in American
history period which is quite a big
claim right you could say we're on track
to do the things I said I would do which
of course would also not be true or some
way make it a less bold statement it's a
ridiculous claim as he made it and the
room made him know that it was
ridiculous
to the point of being literally
laughable settle in for this prepare
yourselves this is what it looks like to
be a total beta on the world stage if
you're allergic to cringe don't watch
this if there are kids in the room get
them out because this is really bad
let's take a look today I stand before
the United Nations General Assembly to
share the extraordinary progress we've
made in less than two years my
administration has accomplished more
than almost any administration
in the history of our country America's
so true
didn't expect that reaction but that's
okay
yes III am like almost feeling slightly
bad for the guy but but I'm not and just
nobody in the room takes him seriously
he's an actual laughing stop stock he is
the literal laughing stock of the
world's leaders and he's talked before
about the United States and the
presidency being laughed at by the world
he was wrong he was talking about Obama
take a listen to this the world is
laughing at us folks they're laughing at
us at our stupidity they laugh at us
laughing at us it's just crazy what's
going on everybody's laughing at us
they're laughing at us
we don't know what we're doing think
we're stupid the whole world is laughing
at us laughing like this that's what's
going on in our country yeah the world
laughs at us folks the world laughs at
it's so funny because I don't remember
laughter at Barack Obama during the
eight years he was president I remember
some laughter with him because he was a
very good speaker and he was able to
very quickly build rapport with with the
audience but now they actually are
laughing at him the entire world is
laughing at Trump world leaders are
laughing at Trump I was just all over
Europe spoke to people in so many
different countries in Europe they are
laughing and scared everywhere and it's
all fun and games and Trump's a [ __ ]
but this is actually more than that
because it's not just Trump it's also
people around him right apparently no
one explained to Trump the dynamics of
speaking at the UN nobody thought maybe
we don't want to put this up on the
teleprompter because when Trump said I
didn't expect that reaction it was
actually like a genuine honest moment
from Trump he really had no idea that
that's how a roomful of world leaders
would react to such a dumb hyperbolic
and unbelievable claim to just laugh at
the absurdity of it and there's a really
interesting other sort of psychological
question which is how is Trump going to
rationalize this after the fact
I saw you an ambassador to the UN nikki
Haley on Fox News I don't even want to
play it for you because it's so so
unbearable but she said something like
oh no they were laughing with him and
they were laughing at the thing he said
after the thing and everybody respected
him and everything I don't even want to
play that people
because it's so dumb I mean that
response would make sense if he was
cracking a joke when you laugh with
someone but that was a serious statement
that he made he was completely serious
and more than likely Trump will say that
people were laughing with him or it was
sort of a brothers-in-arms situation we
all say this stuff we get you good one
Trump he might go on a tirade against
the entire room although it's less
likely in this case because it is the
leaders of basically every every country
around the world this is actually
finally the recognition and reception
that Trump deserves right Trump all
along has deserved to be laughed at by a
roomful of world leaders and he's up
there acting like it's another
presidential rally and expecting I guess
that kind of reaction and all of a
sudden wait a second they're not
clapping they're not cheering they're
laughing at me
yeah you can tell that he's not used to
it I mean his supporters they love the
guy so they're not gonna laugh at him
folks like us folks like you know media
personnel we're all just kind of used to
it we're so desensitized you and we
understand the seriousness of the things
that he says so we're not laughing
either but people like the world leaders
at the UN they don't see the guy too too
often so they're in a position to laugh
they're actually shocked that someone's
showing up and saying this stuff and I
don't want to only focus on the laughing
because Trump's entire speech made no
sense he said positive things about Kim
jong-un he said nothing at all about
Russia he mentioned China in a very
strange and offhanded way and is now
talking about Chinese interference in
American elections still without
mentioning Russian interference he
insisted globalism was bad while clearly
not even understanding what it means
made some thinly veiled attacks on the
United Nations itself and then he
complained about how other countries
aren't giving us money and that was
probably the most surreal moment of the
speech other than the laughingstock
moment where he said we give poor
countries so much money they give us
nothing which makes sense because
they're poor and that's exactly what I
want to talk about next here so Trump
spoke at the United Nations General
Assembly we already talked about how
this roomful of the world's leaders
literally laughed out loud at Donald
Trump's absurd claim that he's done more
in his first two years as president than
any administration in the history of the
entire country
he said a bunch of other wacky stuff
which I already summarized for you what
I want to focus in on now is this
completely just mind-numbing gongshow
comment that Donald Trump made during
the speech where he complained that the
u.s. gives all this money to poor
countries around the world and they
don't give us anything they don't give
us stuff they don't give us money and
Trump seemed sort of indignant or maybe
perplexed about it take a listen to that
part of the speech we are grateful for
all of the work the united nations does
around the world to help people build
better lives for themselves and their
families the United States is the
world's largest giver in the world by
far a foreign aid but few give anything
to us that is why we are taking a hard
look at US foreign assistance that will
be headed up by Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo we will examine what is working
what is not working and whether the
countries who receive our dollars and
our protection also have our interests
at heart so he's talking about a lot of
different countries here but when it
comes to a lot of the aid that we give
we're giving countries money because
they are poor countries they don't give
us money because they are poor countries
but also because what would be the point
of that like am I really helping you if
I give you ten bucks and you give me ten
dollars back now of course that actually
is how a lot of foreign policy works
which is we give a country a billion
bucks but say you've got to spend it
back on buying weapons from American
companies for a billion bucks that's not
how it works with the poor countries
this is just one line from Trump's
speech but it's really kind of
emblematic of the depths of ignorance of
this man he's ignorant about most topics
that he deals with as president and it's
not just the dynamics of foreign aid
that Trump misunderstands look at trade
Trump successfully pretended to be an
expert on trade during the campaign
because he built buildings in Manhattan
pretends to be an expert on trade
completely bamboozled his followers into
thinking that he knows about trade and
now he has us in a completely unwinnable
quagmire of a trade war with China and
increasingly with other countries
foreign policy Trump actually tricked
people with that whole travel ban stuff
and now he's actually had parts of that
harebrained policy made into law on
economics he convinced his followers
again because he built buildings in New
York that not only does he know what's
good for the middle class he is going to
do things that are good for the middle
class and then he passes a tax bill that
gives rich people and corporations a tax
break and will actually increase total
tax liability over the long term for
millions of middle-class people so this
is every single issue when we understand
that and then we go back to who was it
former Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
called him a [ __ ] there's a long litany
v'n have the list Gary Cohn said he's
like talking to a little kid either this
very very long list I'm not even
remembered was something about the
tanning bed that was pretty funny he's
dumber than a tanning bed or there was
another athlete's foot it was like dumb
dumber than a malfunctioning tanning bed
I don't remember exactly it's not
disrespectful it's that the people who
were actually around the guy see the
full scope of that ignorance and as
usual Trump's only half the problem it's
really important not to exculpate his
supporters and his voters right because
Trump claiming that he understands trade
when he doesn't that's bad but unless
people believe him Trump doesn't become
President of the United States right if
it were just Trump being ignorant and
voters saw through it he'd not have won
so it's really really important to
understand that for all the criticisms
of Trump there are some trumpets who
have actually said and we've spoken to
some on the show including like the day
after the election you'll remember that
viral video call pat there are some
people who realize I voted for Trump I
was tricked it was a mistake I'm not
doing it again we've got to get these
people out some people do realize that
but everybody who still supports this
guy is as much a part of the problem as
Trump is
yeah it's like he's a cult leader in a
sense if you're in the cult you think
that he's such an intelligent
guy and you believe everything that he
says sure if you're on the outside
looking in you think it's all ridiculous
it's like Scientology or something else
one of the big Retta me listen there
we've talked about cult psychology a lot
so I don't want to say the biggest but
one way that you can identify whether
there is a sort of cult like nature
building around someone is that there
are constant post hoc rationalizations
so after the the person in this case
Donald Trump has done something you will
see reverse a retrospective rationality
created out of thin air to justify the
action even though that justification
doesn't adhere to any of the principles
that before that action someone would
have said made made sense so for example
that would be like someone says yet you
know I as a as a libertarian believe
that we should have
I don't know as little as a full full
free movement of capital and labor right
and then Donald Trump comes in and he
says well I'm gonna limit the movement
of labor by saying people from these
countries can't come here and we're
gonna build a wall and stop immigration
and he's gonna stop the movement of
capital by putting tariffs on China so
that goes against your principles and
then you say no well listen Trump knows
what he's doing and he's gonna play
tough with these people because the
Mexican leaders and the Chinese leave
hold on a second that's a post hoc
rationalization that goes completely
against the principles you said you
support before Trump did the thing
that's every day and yeah that's a sign
of this cult-like sort of mentality and
it helps when Trump takes every single
position on every single issue at some
point on foreign policy on one day he'll
say that we have to bomb the enemies and
the families of their enemies and then
on the next day he'll say that we have
to stay out of the world's affairs yeah
and that it's Hillary who would start
multiple wars or whatever the case is
send me your thoughts about all of this
UN absolute and total disaster I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show we've got a
good one for you today we've had a
little bit of a break from notable
heckling zuv trump administration and
right-wing officials but i have for you
today arguably the most prominent one in
a long time Ted
crews who ended up leaving his
restaurant date I guess with his wife
yesterday after protesters insisted with
a we believe survivors chant and it was
pretty great and it previously happened
to Trump's Secretary of Homeland
Security
Kristen Nielsen it happened to Trump's
whacky policy adviser Stephen Miller who
was I think trying to have sushi right
let the guy have a salmon roll
yeah Sarah Huckabee Sanders to Huckabee
Sanders at the Red Hen something or
other and I believe West Virginia or
Virginia and now it is Ted Cruz at DC
restaurant Feola where you can get a
beautiful tasting menu for about a
hundred and fifty bucks per person they
will gladly pair it with their grand
wine pairing for an additional two
hundred and ten dollars per person
giving you a delightful evening for
three hundred and sixty bucks per person
at the dinner great restaurant try the
caviar if you get the chance but Ted
Cruz and his wife apparently not able to
check out what happened the video is
from smash racism DC we're gonna play it
for you my two favorite moments of the
video and I want you to listen for both
of these because they're just great
little details in the midst of the we
believe survivors chant at one point
you're gonna hear Cruz in that
cartoonish voice of his say god bless ya
and then the top moment for me is when
one of the protesters says to Cruz that
his opponent Beto or Warrick is way
hotter than he is which is just
brilliant check out the video
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
how dare they ted cruz ended up having
to leave his beautifully paired wine
dinner to go to a nearby 7-eleven and he
had half a dozen of those hot dogs that
they have rotating on the spinner
machines all day not a good night for
Ted Cruz I've gone back and forth on
this okay or maybe not back and forth
I've been nuanced on this saying I
support protesting but not violent
protesting and I've wondered about the
sort of pragmatic effectiveness of any
particular protests like this I am
increasingly on the side that we are
going to need to make people
uncomfortable to achieve change every
time I say this I get angry emails from
from the audience some people even
cancel their memberships I am NOT saying
specifically that heckling Ted Cruz at a
restaurant is going to achieve any
change in the future of Brett
Cavanaugh's confirmation for example
right which is the topic of this protest
I believe survivors but what I am
Telling You is that if protesting was
limited only to the protests that those
in power are comfortable with nothing
would ever change right nothing would
ever change if you go to the people that
maintain the status quo and say mister
mister
Oleg Ark mister person in power whatever
people want change but we want your okay
for how they should protest and advocate
for that change give us the list of how
people should protest they say oh sure
write us letters to our congressional
office and then my aide will file it and
then
you can hold the sign quietly if you
want but it's got to be smaller than 3
feet by 3 feet and you can do it in a
free-speech zone at least 200 feet away
from where I'm going to be speaking know
by definition you have to understand
that protests and civil disobedience and
general strikes like I talked about
yesterday they're not going to be liked
by a lot of people that's the nature of
these things so when people say you're
encouraging disrespectful behavior he's
a public servant but he's allowed to go
to dinner and you David are only saying
it because you disagree with Ted Cruz
and if people did it to bernie you'd be
mad wrong first of all go look at my
commentary from a month or two ago when
Alex Jones heckled Bernie Sanders at an
airport at no point that I say that's
simply going up and heckling him or
asking questions is the problem the
problem is that he's heckling thank him
about things that make no sense and I
disagree with what change he's trying to
bring by heckling Bernie Sanders by the
way in that viral Alex Jones Bernie
video my friend Ari Rabin offed was the
guy traveling with Bernie and I saw him
in New Orleans last month and I asked
him did Bernie really not know who Alex
Jones was or was he playing coy when he
said Ari who is this guy and Ari said no
no it's even better because Bernie
genuinely had no idea who he was he said
after the fact who was that guy Alex
Jones well Marco Rubio took the same
approach to after that Facebook
congressional testimony parted although
I think Marco Rubio knows who Alex Jones
is just pretend he's not relevant though
but back to our primary topic I might
disagree with why you were protesting
but we have a broken democracy here we
have voter suppression we have policy
foreign by the rich it's a straight up
insulting thing to say to suggest you
can't protest non-violently in these
ways we are running out of ways to
effect change they are setting it up so
that you can't disturb the system it's a
shame but heckling politicians is one of
the fewer and fewer remaining ways to
get attention and to express discontent
and as I told you yesterday
you've got stagnant wages you've got
health care that's tied to jobs you've
got people commuting hours to their job
whose wages have not increased for 40
years in real terms we have a system
designed by those in power to prevent
people from having the
timer means to protest in a serious and
effective manner civil disobedience
general strikes heckling politicians you
can do this stuff and I say good for you
I might argue with them Pat because I
might say well I don't agree with the
cause you're protesting for or I think
you're on the wrong side of an issue but
I'm not going to say this is
disrespectful and you can't do it
because we have increasingly fewer and
fewer ways to actually protest and of
course the best case scenario is Ted
Cruz getting voted out in November bait
overwork replacing him yeah but even
then Cruz is gonna be a senator until
January and he's probably going to be
able to vote on that Cavanaugh
confirmation if you happen on whoever
else Trump picks no doubt so you have to
be able to do more you have to and if
you still disagree with me on this let
me know I'm ready and willing and I hope
people will call in during during live
calls on the Friday show and tell me if
you disagree and we can talk about it so
Donald Trump gave his first press
conference in a while yesterday and it
very very quickly devolved into a sort
of deranged house of horrors and I'm
going to highlight it for you I couldn't
look away I had it on initially just
kind of in the background thinking I
would sort of listen but it very quickly
became the type of thing I really had to
focus my entire attention on and of
course the context of this press
conference is it comes the day after
Trump was laughed at by the entirety of
the United Nations special
General Assembly we discussed that a
couple of times now Donald Trump decided
to hold this press conference the day
before these hearings in which his
Supreme Court pick Brett Kavanaugh would
be under oath after his accuser
Christine Blasi Ford would be under oath
and we will get to that a little bit
later in the show and this press
conference has completely reinvigorated
the questions about Donald Trump's
cognitive capacity the the questions
about his awareness of basic facts have
been around for a while but the the
questions about the cognitive capacity
are fully back enforced so I'm gonna
show you a few things from this press
conference the first is maybe the most
nuanced during his United Nations speech
Donald Trump talked about China
interfering in American elections but he
of conspicuously given what's been going
on made no mention at all of Russia
interfering in American elections and a
journalist asked him a very reasonable
question which was how do you compare
what you accused China of doing to what
Russia has done and Trump panicked
clearly didn't want to answer that
question and managed to give a rambling
disjointed answer that didn't even
mention Russia at all it barely even
related to Chinese interference either
so stick with this we're going to go
through it notice that there is no
answer and then almost immediately when
this answer is done
Trump ends the press conference so let's
take it from the top there are two small
follow-ups one is how would you compare
the level of interference you see today
from the Chinese to what Russia did in
2016 well I think it's different if you
look at the Des Moines Register I'm
going to have ads that are made to look
like editorials saying about oh you got
to stop Trump you got to stop him you
got a vote against him my farmers are
some card these are patriots you know on
a network that doesn't like me very much
which is most of them but a network that
didn't doesn't really treat me very good
they interviewed farmers and they got
hurt because you know all of a sudden
China steps by by the way they've
started buying again I don't know if you
have noticed and soybeans are going up
and things are going up and we've had
very little hurt from what I've done
in fact the markets have gone up and the
farmers are going to do great but
ultimately but they had farmers and
these guys amazing I love them and they
voted for me and they love me and they
said we don't care if we get hurt he's
doing the right thing and you know a lot
of people it's a complex game a lot of
people don't know exactly what it is
they don't know how to define tariff
they don't know it is very different
than a tax although it's getting close
yeah so bear in mind he talks about
soybeans he talks about farmers he talks
about networks that don't quote treat
him good he talks about the stock market
and everybody's going to do great
no answer to the question how do you
compare the scope of what you claimed
China did to
Russia did and it continues we've
skipped over nothing here okay we're not
jumping ahead at all we're picking it up
from where we just left off this is
still presumably part of his answer
about Russian and Chinese interference
in the election remember the question
was compare the degree of Chinese
election interference to Russian
election interference but they know that
for the first time in many many years
they have a president that's fighting
for them
that's not letting their jobs be taken
to other countries that's not allowing
the kind of abuse that we I mean when
you look at what happened as an example
with NAFTA and for years because it was
never changed NAFTA was a defective deal
the day it was signed you know why
because they had a VAT tax of 17 percent
and nobody from this country knew that
and by the time they found out which was
about a week later nobody went and
changed it so you went many years and
they never changed it there was a VAT
tax that Mexico God so we were 17 or 16
points behind before we even started
NAFTA was a horrible thing
remember the question Russian election
interference he's talking about NAFTA
and trade deals VAT taxes Mexico and
then continuing here were not cutting
anything out this is still the same
answer Trump continues so the farmers
and by the way the Steel Workers you
know I stopped the dumping the dumping
was horrible and now they want a dump
that's okay but they've got to pay the
United States of America 25 percent on
everything they dump that's okay yeah
but as I told you before steel is doing
phenomenally well but the farmers say
this man's fighting for us no president
has ever fought for us before and you
really have to study what's happened
over the 15 years with a farm the
farmers have been decimated over a 15
year period
they've been decimated the farmers are
gonna come out great these are great
people they're great great Patriots I
think we should finish with that one is
that okay yes and the Congress
go ahead let's go fast
stunning not even a pretend answer the
question was compare the degree of
Chinese election interference to Russian
election interference he talked about
almost everything but that like he
didn't get you know word about that I
would have loved it if the reporter who
followed up asked the exact same
question that's the strategy I would
like to see the media employee but sure
it didn't happen not here they had their
own questions to move on to other crazy
moments Trump claiming that China
respects his very large brain when China
he was on a good show I won't mention
the name of the show recently and he was
saying that China has total respect for
Donald Trump and for Donald Trump's very
very large brain he said down Donald
Trump they don't know what to do never
happen is it's not a large brain it's a
large brain and then here is Trump
saying that when there are sexual
assault allegations he tends to side
with the accused not the accuser this is
kind of an interesting take and notice
that in this clip you have to pay
attention to this okay I'm gonna play
for you a minute and a half clip in this
minute and a half within actually about
55 seconds he claims never to have met
the women that accused him of sexual
assault and to have known them 15 to 20
years ago okay same clip same 60 seconds
he says women who I've never met accused
me and women who I knew they were
actually women who I knew 15 to 20 years
ago how can both be true how your
personal experiences being accused by
more than I've been accused I've been
accused me false accusation excuse me
I've been accused and I was accused by I
believe it was four women you can do
check with Sean Hannity you can check
with Fox because they covered it very
strongly they know yeah who got paid
excuse me excuse me I was accused by
four or five women who got paid a lot of
money to make up stories about me we
caught them and the mainstream media
refused to put it on television they
refused even write about it there were
four women and maybe more
I think the numbers four or five sixteen
but one had a mortgage paid off her
house $52,000 another one had other
things happen and the one that reported
it I believe was offered seven hundred
and fifty thousand dollars to say bad
things about me and she is the one that
reported it this woman is incredible she
reported it instead of taking the money
so I've had numerous accusations about
me
we know they mean they made false
statements about me knowing they were
false I never met him I never met these
people never and what did they do what
did they do they took money in order to
say bad things I've had stories written
in the New York Times front page about
four women the whole top-center front
page of the New York Times I think it
was four big pictures I said wow that's
a big thing what said these were women
that were quoted saying bad things about
me not the worst things about me but bad
things and I said gee that's too bad I
knew him a long time ago 15 years ago 20
years ago I said that's too bad I'm
surprised at them within 60 seconds he
says he never met the people and that he
knew them 15 to 20 years ago is anybody
listening this is a serial uncontained
liar and then cherry on top when
answering about Brett Kavanaugh sexual
assault and this is just where I don't
know how history will even explain this
he seems to say here that George
Washington the first president of the
United States had sexual assault
allegations against him which he seems
to know about but weren't widely
reported or something take a listen look
if we brought George Washington here and
we said we have George Washington the
Democrats would vote against him just so
you understand right and he may have had
a bad pass to an us you know he may have
had some I think accusations made didn't
he have a couple of things in his past
George Washington would be voted against
100% by Schumer and the con artists I
mean 100 percent know how to do
historians report about this in the
future I mean this goes beyond being
valid for basic political political
analysis and it becomes more a
a sociological cultural aberration the
likes of which we've never seen before
and I hope we'll never see again but
that's actually my fear my fear is that
we will I'm scared that this is what the
United States is becoming because
remember that 40% nearly 40% of the
country supports this they support this
guy absolute house of horrors press
conference send me your thoughts about
it if you saw it I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show this is a story you might
find really strange to hear and rest
assured it's a very strange story for me
to tell you it's about the Spanish
Foreign Minister Donald Trump suggested
to Spain that they deal with the
migration from Africa to Europe by
building a wall across the Sahara Desert
Donald Trump also suggested that quote
the Sahara border can't be bigger than
our border with Mexico so let's actually
look at a map if you're watching on TV
or on YouTube you might notice here that
the Sahara Desert is in Africa not in
Europe it spans roughly ten countries
none of which are Spain Trump references
and we can keep this up
Trump references the Sahara border which
also makes no sense since the Sahara
isn't really a border it's not exactly
clear what Donald Trump means by that
this would make it very difficult for
Spain to build a wall across legally
speaking and it also as you can tell is
very very big it happens to be more than
3,000 miles across which is more than
50% longer than the us-mexico border
that Trump was referring to and then
lastly as if we need more reasons for
why this makes no sense Donald Trump
seems to have no idea whatsoever that
Spain's economic problems which I guess
is what he was addressing predate the
so-called immigration crisis in Europe
and hilariously there there is actually
something called a Saharan wall it's a
project that's underway it's called the
great green wall but it's not a wall
meant to stop immigrants from coming
through it's a wall of trees meant to
stop climate change to mitigate climate
change not immigrants I'm actually
shocked that Trump hasn't just called
for a wall to
built around all of Africa right that
seems based on his immigration ideas
around skin color the wall he he would
more likely be interested in I mean just
to take a look at history though the
Arabs did invade Spain in the year like
700 AD so you like that and occupied it
for quite a while it could do it there
there is historical precedent here of
course with the Arabs be coming from
Africa at this point is another relevant
question but not one I think that Donald
Trump is equipped to answer at this time
yeah and the Strait of Gibraltar between
Spain and Morocco it's only like 10
miles long you could swim that out long
enough a good enough swimmer could
definitely swim swim across that if
we're really thinking about walls to
build maybe Trump should propose one up
the entire Pacific Ocean to stop trade
with China right in the same way that
one with Mexico would stop anybody from
coming in this is what you get when you
have someone who hasn't read a book in
his adult life has no genuine curiosity
about the world and in addition is born
with a silver spoon in his mouth and
starts a business with a small loan of
just a million dollars from his dad this
is how you get to this level of
ignorance and Donald Trump has said and
done very dumb things during his
presidency so far but this is a level of
political and geographic idiocy that I
just didn't think was possible for a 70
year old college-educated adult in the
United States I think the Sahara Desert
should pay for the wall what about you
Lee yeah there you by the way who would
even pay for it in that case right and
actually maybe that's the most this is
kind of a just a story pointing out how
dumb the people representing us are
maybe the question should be is this
simply ignorance is it insanity or is it
dementia right because Trump did take
that dementia test he was able to tell a
lion in a camel apart so that proves
that that he's fine obviously according
to him so maybe he is truly this
ignorant and I don't know how you defend
this even if you're one of trumps
strongest supporters right like don't
you have to say okay listen I defend the
guy because I like his trade policy but
that was one of the dumbest things I've
ever heard of they would just deny that
it ever happened or they say that he'd
be a private conversation between Trump
and the Spanish for
mr. fake news that's what I tell you
please please tell me that history will
not look back kindly at this guy I I
need to believe that just to make it
through to the next day and I'm really
struggling because I worry that a
hundred years from now this guy's legacy
will be whitewashed to such a degree
that he'll be sort of wrapped up as he
was another one of those late 2000s and
early 1990s and early 2000s presidents
who yeah you know he didn't do great but
he didn't do better
yeah I mean George Bush now is being as
being seen by some in a positive light I
mean I did after all give Michelle Obama
a piece of candy yes that's true so the
war crimes there were in Iraq the
economic downturn that's all forgiven
it's all seemingly forgiven knowing
that's a real and we've talked about
that just because we point out that even
George Bush had a certain amount of
basic decorum that he adhered to and
whatever else we're not in any way
exculpating Bush's disastrous foreign
and domestic policy it's really really
important to make that point